actually it's contessa valentina allegri
to fountain
i know it's hard but i don't like to
repeat myself so you can just call me
val
but don't call me val just keep it in
your head once
she's in frame she lights the whole
thing up what was it like having her
there
well you know i had to get i had to fan
out for a little bit so i did all that
no she was a delight and really you know
thoughtful about the character one of
the things that
we do uh is draw from the comics but we
don't
duplicate the actors are very encouraged
to
bring their own interpretation to the
character and so she
it was really fun to develop this this
woman with her
uh right down to the earrings and the
and the the look and the boots and the
the whole thing and the purple streak in
her hair and watch her bring them
bring val
[Laughter]
by the way don't worry about the shield
i know you don't have it
here's a little dirty state secret
that doesn't really belong to the
government is there a scene
from any of these episodes that you did
that
that you are so proud of it was in
episode two where they
um sam and bucky face the uh
the therapist
just blank sweet jesus goes from
comedy to extreme drama and the guys
really found that scene in in the moment
that shield
that is that is everything he stood for
that is his legacy he gave you that
shield and you threw it away like it was
nothing
so maybe he was wrong about you and if
he was wrong about you then he was wrong
about me
the actors are very aware of their
characters because they've been playing
them for several years
so uh but we were now going to spend a
lot more time with them
than we had in any of the movies or any
of the work that they'd done before
we were going to go home with them we
were going to you know get inside
their lives anthony is a really smart
actor and he really
does his homework and thinks very deeply
about the character so when he comes in
every day he is full of fresh ideas
i think he really enjoyed this this the
path of discovery for a character that
became very fresh for him
um because we he was able to embody
him in a new way they will
never let a black man be captain america
and even if they did no self-respecting
black man
would ever want to be do you see um
stories that can be told as a season two
of this
like is there something you want to
tackle next
well i'd love there to be a season two
no one has no one has confirmed to
season two
so we'll see it with these new
characters of
um you know bucky and sam and we
even zemo and sharon and valentina
john walker i mean we've got this lovely
um a basket full of stories potential
stories
which i uh every one of them is worthy
because every one of them gonna tackle
in some way
a trope or a norm that we we have
accepted as being the only way it is and
they're gonna
they're gonna do what we just did which
is you know blow it wide open
what can you tell us about how things
sort of i guess come to a head
at the end of the show well i would
be uh there would be a bolt of lightning
that comes down if i actually told you
what's gonna happen
but i can say it's very moving
uh and it's absolutely kick-ass action